This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个I-Heart播客。保证真人。2%。这是当电梯旁也有自动扶梯时，选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客“2%”中，我将剖析我们这个奇异的现代世界中关于心理韧性、健身和培养抗挫力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology.
经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在经历另一端变成一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。收听“2%”。在IHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方搜索数字“2. percent”。大家好，欢迎回到你的二十岁心理学，这是一个探讨我们在二十岁时经历的一些重大生活变化和转变，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么的播客。
Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is. just a delight to have you back here for another episode for a special episode as we break down the psychology of our 20s. So today, we're talking about a subject that I get asked about a whole lot and that I think actually is one of those core experiences that really defines our 20s, especially for a lot of people who listen to this podcast. It's travel. Traveling the world, gap years, semesters abroad, road trips, Euro summers, sightseeing, solo traveling.
大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。无论你是新听友、老听友，还是身处世界的哪个角落。很高兴你能回来收听另一期节目，收听我们剖析二十岁心理学的特别节目。所以今天，我们要谈论一个经常有人问我的话题，我认为它实际上是真正定义我们二十岁核心经历之一，特别是对许多收听这个播客的人来说。这就是旅行。环游世界、间隔年、海外学期、自驾游、欧洲之夏、观光、独自旅行。
These are all things that are on, I would say a lot of our bucket list for those of us in our 20s, because I think a real theme for this decade for many of us is exploration and expansion and growth and having as many experiences as possible. And travel just fits so neatly into that. Travel just has such a magnetic pull during this chapter. of our life. You know, psychologists often call our 20s like a developmental sweet spot for new experiences and for experiences that are going to disrupt our routine and expand our worldview. They say that this period is when those opportunities are most formative. So if you have the
这些都是我们二十岁的人愿望清单上的事情，因为我认为对于我们许多人来说，这十年的一个真正主题是探索、拓展、成长，并尽可能多地拥有各种经历。而旅行恰好非常契合这一点。在我们生命的这个阶段，旅行有着一种磁石般的吸引力。你知道，心理学家经常把我们的二十岁称为新经历的“发展甜蜜点”，这些经历将打破我们的常规并拓展我们的世界观。他们说，这一时期正是这些机遇最具塑造力的时候。所以，如果你有
opportunity to travel and to see the world or just to go to the next town over during this decade, you should absolutely take it because you're going to see so much better. benefit from something that is also just probably very, very enjoyable. You know, during this time when we are trying to figure out who we are, we're trying to figure out our career, we're trying to figure out what kind of life we want to leave. Travel really helps us in this process because it pulls us out of familiar contexts and it makes us see the world differently and it makes us, you know, at times uncomfortable and it challenges us and it makes us see that the world is large and expansive. and that's really what we need to believe in our 20s in order to, I guess, open doors for ourselves
机会在这十年里去旅行、去看世界，或者哪怕只是去隔壁的小镇，你绝对应该抓住这个机会，因为你会从中获得巨大的好处，而且这也可能是一件非常非常享受的事情。你知道，在这个我们试图弄清楚自己是谁、试图搞清楚自己的职业、试图弄清楚我们想留下什么样生活的时期。旅行确实在这一过程中帮助了我们，因为它把我们从熟悉的环境中拉出来，让我们以不同的方式看待世界，让我们（你知道的）有时感到不舒服，它挑战我们，让我们看到世界是宏大而广阔的
in order to explore all the different possibilities. You know, in everyday life we're surrounded by all the same things, the same cultural norms, the same routines, the same people. When we travel, whether, you know, we're moving to a new city or we're visiting a foreign country or whatever it is, we strip away all of that normalcy. And in the absence of those familiar cues, we're really, really being forced to look inward and kind of decide for ourselves that we are capable and decide for ourselves how we want to think and how we want to act and how we want to connect. I think on top of that,
而这正是我们在二十岁时需要去相信的，我想，这样才能为自己打开大门，以便探索所有不同的可能性。你知道，在日常生活中，我们被所有相同的事物所包围，相同的文化规范、相同的常规、相同的人。当我们旅行时，无论是（你知道的）搬到一个新城市，还是参观一个外国，或者不管是什么，我们都剥离了所有的正常状态。在缺乏这些熟悉线索的情况下，我们真的、真的被迫进行内省，并为自己做出决定——我们是有能力的，并为自己决定我们想如何思考、我们想如何行动以及我们想如何建立连接。我认为除此之外，
the reason people love travel during this decade is, of course, it's fun, but it also just makes for really great and iconic stories that we're going to pass down to our kids and our grandkids or to our friends at a nursing home or wherever it is. They become like, fibers that kind of create our life, really. They become the fibers of this tapestry and of this thing that we're creating. So let's talk about the psychology of travel and why traveling actually is one of the best things we can do for our development during this decade. Firstly, travel brings about a profound sense of cognitive flexibility.
人们在这十年里热爱旅行的原因，当然是因为它很有趣，但它也能成就非常棒且具有标志性的故事，我们可以把这些故事传给我们的孩子和孙子，或者传给养老院的朋友，无论在哪里。它们真的就像构成我们生活的纤维。它们成为了这幅挂毯的纤维，成为了我们正在创造的事物的纤维。所以让我们来谈谈旅行的心理学，以及为什么旅行实际上是我们在这十年发展中能做的最好的事情之一。首先，旅行会带来深刻的认知灵活性。
Cognitive flexibility is basically our ability to experience, new things, new circumstances, new situations, and problem solved despite never being exposed to them before. It's basically our ability to adapt to new ways of thinking and new challenges that we've never encountered. This is one of the most essential skills that our brain develops in early adulthood. You cannot really get anywhere without it, and it is heightened, in fact, through exposure to novel environments like those we find abroad or like those we find traveling. There is actually a science to back this up. A 2010 study found that people who lived abroad for a semester demonstrated when they returned higher levels of cognitive flexibility and also
认知灵活性基本上是我们体验新事物、新环境、新情况，并在从未接触过它们的情况下解决问题的能力。这基本上是我们适应从未遇到过的新思维方式和新挑战的能力。这是我们的在大脑成年早期发展的最基本技能之一。没有它，你真的什么也做不了，而事实上，通过接触新颖的环境（比如我们在国外或旅行中发现的环境），这种能力会得到提升。实际上有科学依据来支持这一点。2010年的一项研究发现，在国外生活了一个学期的留学生在返回后表现出了更高水平的认知灵活性，并且还
higher levels of creativity, which is related to cognitive flexibility because when they were within this new culture, they had to adapt and they saw new things. I had to find solutions to unfamiliar problems. They had to negotiate a new kind of way of understanding and a new meaning. You know, travel doesn't just show us new places and it isn't just about the joy of the experience. It actually rewires our thinking very deeply. We become more comfortable with ambiguity, more willing to embrace complexity and more able to really hold multiple perspectives in our mind at once. It's just such an invaluable skill that I think people don't really appreciate when you know, they're having drinks on a beach in Bali or they're at a hotel in the city over. Like,
表现出更高水平的创造力，这与认知灵活性有关，因为当他们处于这种新文化中时，他们必须适应并看到新事物。我必须为不熟悉的问题找到解决方案。他们必须协商一种新的理解方式和新的意义。你知道，旅行不仅向我们展示了新地方，也不仅仅关乎体验的快乐。它实际上非常深刻地重塑了我们的思维。我们变得更能适应模糊性，更愿意拥抱复杂性，也更能真正在脑海中同时持有多种观点。这是一种如此宝贵的技能，我认为人们在（你知道的）在巴厘岛的海滩上喝饮料或在隔壁城市的酒店里时，并没有真正去体会这一点。
they don't realize what they're doing for their brain. It's incredibly powerful. There's also a deeply personal element to this as well. Many of us grow up in environments that are very, very controlled. We have our school schedule. We have our family routine. We have cultural expectations. during this decade is the first time that we really want to deliberately step away from these boundaries or push back against these boundaries and find out who we are without them. It's a period of individuation. And travel is such a tangible way for us to actually test this newfound independence and this new sense of self. It does this by challenging what the psychologist Albert Bandura called our self-efficacy. I wish we talked about self-efficacy more.
他们没有意识到自己在为自己的大脑做什么。这是非常强大的。这里面还有一个非常个人化的元素。我们许多人在非常、非常受控的环境中长大。我们有学校的时间表。我们有家庭常规。我们有文化期望。在这十年中，这是我们第一次真正想要刻意走出这些界限，或者反抗这些界限，并找出没有这些界限时我们是谁。这是一个个体化时期。而旅行对我们来说是一个非常切实的方式，来检验这种新获得的独立感和新的自我意识。它通过挑战心理学家阿尔伯特·班杜拉（Albert Bandura）所谓的自我效能感来做到这一点。我希望我们能更多地谈论自我效能感。
It is just such a powerful concept. Basically, it's our ability to trust that we can handle challenges. Basically, how much do we believe that we are capable of dealing with things that are difficult or that we can't necessarily, yeah, predict? For example, you know, with travel, self-efficacy is tested in the sense that we have to ask ourselves, do I trust myself to be able to navigate this new city? Do I trust myself to be okay if things go wrong? Because with travel, something will always go wrong. Do I trust myself to be able to plan and make good decisions? Whether you think you can or not, travel is going to force you to do it anyway. And that is essentially a kind of baptism by fire whereby we are forced to see and forced to be made aware of how truly capable we are. that in a way that we can't always do in everyday normal environments. And that really leads to like an important part of travel in our 20s. It's not always glamorous. It can be messy. It can be exhausting.
这真是一个如此强大的概念。基本上，这是我们相信自己能够应对挑战的能力。基本上，我们有多大程度相信自己有能力处理困难的事情，或者我们不一定能（是的）预测的事情？例如，（你知道的）在旅行中，自我效能感会受到考验，因为我们要问自己，我信任自己能够在这个新城市中导航吗？如果事情出错了，我信任自己能安然无恙吗？因为在旅行中，总会有事情出错。我信任自己能够计划并做出好的决定吗？无论你认为自己能否做到，旅行都会迫使你无论如何都要去做。这本质上是一种“烈火洗礼”，通过它，我们被迫看到并被迫意识到自己真正有多大能力，这种方式我们在日常正常环境中并不总能做到。这确实引导我们走向旅行在二十岁时的一个重要部分。它并不总是光鲜亮丽的。它可能是混乱的。它可能是令人筋疲力尽的。
It can be uncomfortable, you know, language barriers and long bus rides and lost luggage and uncomfortable plane rides. But those less than perfect moments actually serve a really important psychological purpose in that they teach us resilience. They show us that. They show us that Discomfort isn't something to fear, but something to move through. This is what we call inoculation by stress or stress inoculations. Essentially, when we experience challenges and when we experience stress, actually that makes us, I guess, less likely to be stressed in the future. It's inoculating us or protecting us against future spikes in stress levels because
它可能会让人不舒服，（你知道的）语言障碍、长途大巴、丢失的行李和不舒服的飞机行程。但那些不够完美的时刻实际上服务于一个非常重要的心理目的，那就是它们教给我们韧性。它们向我们展示了。它们向我们展示了不适并不是需要恐惧的东西，而是需要去穿越的东西。这就是我们所说的压力接种或压力接种。本质上，当我们经历挑战和压力时，实际上这会使我们（我想）在未来不那么容易感到压力。它为我们接种疫苗或保护我们免受未来压力水平激增的影响，因为
we have this evidence within us that we can handle it. We have these experiences to look back on and say, oh, okay, I've been here before. I've done this before. I've survived. I've had positive experiences out of negative experiences. So I'm going to be okay. I'm going to be just fine. There is another beautiful outcome of travel beyond just cute pictures and souvenirs and fun memories and beverages and whatever else there is. It also brought, broadens our sense of empathy. Social psychologists have for a long, long time known that exposure to diverse perspectives reduces prejudice, it increases understanding, the more time you spend in another culture around people that you've never met before who you may not understand, the more you
我们内心有这种证据，证明我们可以应对它。我们可以回顾这些经历并说：哦，好吧，我以前来过这里。我以前做过。我活下来了。我从消极的经历中获得了积极的经历。所以我不会有事的。我会没事的。除了可爱的照片、纪念品、快乐的回忆、饮料和任何其他东西之外，旅行还有另一个美丽的成果。它还拓宽了我们的同理心。长期以来，社会心理学家一直都知道，接触不同的视角可以减少偏见，增加理解。你在另一种文化中度过的时间越多，周围都是你从未见过、你可能并不理解的人，你就越
begin to see that the things you thought were universal are not, and there is more than one way to be human and you learn to respect that your way is not the best way. That is such a fundamental shift and it's one that I think we could all obviously be enduring more, experiencing more. The world feels so polarized. That ability, though, to see the common humanity beneath all our, beneath what the like surface level differences is a very quiet but radical skill and one that I think we could all agree more people need. Maybe travel is actually the solution to that. Getting out into the world is a way to bring people into this understanding. Also, you know, you build relationships. We know that incidental intimacy and having joint
开始看到，你以为是普遍存在的东西其实并不是，人类的存在方式不止一种，你学会尊重你的方式并不是最好的方式。这是一个如此根本的转变，我认为我们显然都可以在这方面坚持更多、体验更多。世界感觉如此两极分化。然而，看到所有这些差异、表面差异之下的共同人性的能力，是一种非常安静但激进的技能，我认为大家都同意我们需要更多这样的人。也许旅行真的是解决这个问题的办法。走向世界是让人们理解这一点的一种方式。此外，（你知道的）你建立了关系。我们知道，偶然的亲密感，以及与那些艰难的、非常深刻的、情绪化的、不可思议的、深刻的人共同
experiences with people that are tough or really deep or emotional, incredible, profound, they make the bond between you and another person even more deep. You know, there's something about being away from home that really encourages a new level of openness. When you don't have the baggage of other people's expectations or you don't have your usual role or your usual routine, you often feel a lot more freer to be vulnerable and to share things and to be like, you know, I've never told anyone this, but this is, you know, I'm processing this like in the moment. whilst I'm experiencing these new things with this new person and that intimacy, it's just like incredibly profound. And it's like no wonder that people come back from trips and they just have a new lease on life
经历，会使你与另一个人之间的联系更加深厚。你知道，远离家乡的某些东西确实鼓励了一种新水平的开放。当你没有别人期望的包袱，或者你没有你通常的角色或通常的常规时，你通常会感到更加自由，可以去脆弱，去分享事情，去表现得像（你知道的）我从来没有告诉过任何人这个，但这（你知道的）我正在像这样实时处理它。当我与这个新的人一起经历这些新事物时，这种亲密感简直是难以置信的深刻。难怪人们旅行归来后，他们对生活有了一种新的看法，
and they see the world clearer and they feel like they know themselves better because they're going through all of these deep psychological changes that they don't even recognize. I also think that there is a pragmatic reason why our 20s are often the best time to travel. We have very few responsibilities, well, fewer than what we may have later in life. And travel is becoming more accessible. We've got budget airlines. We've got work exchange programs, remote work as well as becoming a lot more popular. There are all these new platforms that offer affordable accommodation.
他们能更清晰地看清世界，并觉得他们更了解自己，因为他们正在经历所有这些甚至都没有意识到的深层心理变化。我也认为，我们的二十岁往往是旅行的最佳时间，这背后有一个务实的原因。我们的责任很少，嗯，比我们以后生活中可能要少。而且旅行正变得越来越容易。我们有廉价航空公司。我们有工作交换项目，远程工作也变得越来越受欢迎。有所有这些提供经济实惠住宿的新平台。
And it's just like opened the world up to us in a way that previous generations didn't have the same privileges as us. it definitely is still a privilege and it is still something that is just like incredibly, we are incredibly blessed and lucky to be able to do, but it's no longer solely reserved for people who are incredibly wealthy. And this accessibility matters because it means more people are seeing the developmental benefits and the mindset benefits and the empathy benefits and all the benefits of of seeing the world and of going out there and having experiences that make them feel more in touch with your human side and that make you feel more aligned with who you are and what you want from the world and what you want from humanity and what you want from your life.
它就像以一种前代人没有我们这样的特权的方式向我们打开了世界。它绝对仍然是一种特权，它仍然是一件（就像）令人难以置信的事情，我们能够做到这一点是极其有福气和幸运的，但它不再仅仅保留给那些极其富有的人。这种可及性很重要，因为这意味着更多的人正在看到发展的好处、心态的好处、同理我知道这太疯狂了，当你谈论旅行时，人们就会说：哦，是的，我有趣的春假旅行，然后就好像：不，这里有深刻的心理原则，并且有你对生活的一种叙事，正被这些难怪年纪较大的人总是想重温旅行故事，或者总有一些在飞行中、船上或异国他乡发生的精彩的改变生活的故事，因为这些是我们生命中的高光时刻。它们是我们自我意识的锚点，也是对我们曾经勇敢、好奇、在这个世界上充满活力、感觉像我们自己的时刻的提醒。现在，我想说的是：也许其中最美妙的事情之一
I know it's so crazy when you talk about travel people are just like, oh yes, my fun like spring break trip and it's like, no, there are deep psychological principles and there is a, a narrative that is being, that you have about your life that is being shaped by these experiences. No wonder people who are older always want to recount the travel stories or always have some brilliant life-changing story that happened when they were flying or on a boat or in a foreign place because these are high points in our life. They are anchor points for our sense of self and reminders of the times when we were bold and we were curious and we were alive in the world and we felt like ourselves. Now, I want to say this. Perhaps one of the most
我知道这太疯狂了，当你谈论旅行时，人们会觉得，哦，对，我有趣的春假旅行之类的。但实际上，并非如此，这里面有着深刻的心理学原则，还有一种由这些经历塑造的关于你生活的叙事。难怪年纪大的人总是喜欢重温他们的旅行故事，或者总能讲出一些在飞机上、船上或异国他乡发生的精彩绝伦、改变人生故事，因为这些是我们人生的最高峰。它们是我们自我意识的锚点，提醒着我们曾经勇敢、充满好奇心、在这个世界上充满活力并且找回自我的时刻。现在，我想说的是。也许这是最
beautiful things about traveling in our 20s is that it does not have to be grand and elaborate and expensive. There is undeniable magic in, you know, I don't know, walking the Pacific Cross Trail or seeing the Eiffel Tower or going on your dream trip. But actually some of the most impactful experiences do come from smaller moments, like the trip that was only an hour car ride away or a weekend in an Airbnb. You know, we place a lot of emphasis on big destinations, but it turns out you can receive the wonder and joy of travel from just about any new environment you haven't been in before. In the end, I think it really all comes down to, are you witnessing things you have never witnessed before in your life? Are you experiencing the
在二十岁时旅行的好处在于，它不必是宏大、复杂和昂贵的。无可否认，其中蕴含着魔力，（你知道的）我不知道，走太平洋山脊径、看埃菲尔铁塔或去你的梦想之旅。但实际上，一些最具影响力的经历确实来自于更小的时刻，比如只是一小时车程的旅行或在Airbnb上的周末。你知道，我们对宏大的目的地赋予了很大的重视，但事实证明，你几乎可以从任何你以前没去过的新环境中获得旅行的惊奇和喜悦。最后，我认为这 realmente 归结为：你是否在见证你生活中从未见过的事物？你是否在体验
novelty of this moment. Are you growing in ways and are you challenging yourself in ways that perhaps you wouldn't have? Are you just seeing the world differently? That is really where the power of this comes from. With that in mind, though, traveling can also kind of take a toll on us emotionally and physically and mentally, which is something we don't talk about all the time. But it turns out there are a lot of people out there interested in and researching how to travel better so that we can get the most out of our trips, get the most out of this experience, starting with the flight, starting with the moment we leave our house. And I got the privilege of being able to interview one of those very people. So stay tuned. Stick around for more.
这个时刻的新奇感。你是否在以某种方式成长，并以你可能不会的方式挑战自己？你是否只是以不同的方式看待世界？这才是这种力量真正来源的地方。话虽如此，旅行也会在情绪、身体和精神上对我们造成某种损害，这是我们并不总是谈论的事情。但事实证明，有很多人对如何更好地旅行感兴趣并进行研究，这样我们就能充分利用我们的旅行，充分利用这种体验，从飞行开始，从我们离开家的那一刻开始。我有幸能够采访这样一个人。所以敬请期待。留下来了解更多。
We're going to dive even deeper into this topic after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange, modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong.
在这段简短的休息之后，我们将更深入地探讨这个话题。2%。这是当电梯旁也有自动扶梯时，选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客“2%”中，我将剖析我们这个奇异的现代世界中关于心理韧性、健身和培养抗挫力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，看穿在健康产业中占主导地位的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。
Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. So now that we've discussed the psychology and the emotional importance of travel in our 20s, I want to get a little bit further into the physicality of it, the biology of it, the science of kind of travel and well-being. And like I said, this is not my area of expertise. Yes, I jump on an airplane every now and again, but I wanted to talk to someone who really understood all the other sides of this better than me and who better than Dr. Henry,
我们在世界上惊慌失措的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在经历另一端变成一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。收听“2%”。在I-Hart电台应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方搜索“T-W-O-Persent”。既然我们已经讨论了二十岁时旅行的心理学和情感重要性，我想更深入地探讨它的身体层面、生物学层面以及关于旅行和幸福的科学。正如我所说，这并不是我的专业领域。是的，我偶尔会跳上一架飞机，但我想和一个比我更好地理解这一切其他方面的人聊聊，还有谁比亨利·丁博士更合适呢？
Ting, who is a world-renowned cardiologist. He also joined Delta Airlines in 2021 as the Global Airlines Chief Health and Wellness Officer. There is quite literally no better person, I think, to talk to about this than him. Welcome, Dr. Ting. Pleasure to be here with you, Gemma. I'm very, very excited for this. Before we jump into the questions that I have for you about your research and Delta's research, can we just know a little bit more about you and your background as a doctor? Yeah, thanks, Gemma. First, please call me Henry. I'm not your doctor, but I'm a cardiologist by training.
他是一位世界知名的心脏病专家。他还于2021年加入达美航空，担任全球航空公司首席健康与保健官。我想，真的没有比他更合适的人选来谈论这个了。欢迎，丁博士。很高兴能和您在一起，杰玛。我对此感到非常、非常兴奋。在我们深入探讨我关于您的研究和达美航空研究的问题之前，能让我们多了解一下您以及您作为医生的背景吗？好的，谢谢，杰玛。首先，请叫我亨利。我不是你的医生，但我的专业背景是心脏病学。
I trained in Boston and worked for over 20 years at the Mayo Clinic in Rochester, Minnesota. And I joined Delta Airlines in 2021, as you said, as the airline's first chief health and wellness officer. Which is honestly such a cool concept because I had never thought about the fact that spending time in the air is such a weird thing for you. humans to be doing. And it obviously like does sometimes affect us like mentally and physically in terms of jet lag and in terms of well-being. So the fact that that you've like joined in that capacity is super cool. I also want to talk more specifically about a recent experiment that you guys kind of conducted. So you guys have launched a new campaign in a new series that really explores the connection between travel and well-being. But as part of that, you did some
我在波士顿受过培训，并在明尼苏达州罗切斯特的梅奥诊场工作了20多岁。正如你所说，我于2021年加入达美航空，担任该航空公司的首任首席健康与保健官。老实说，这是一个非常酷的概念，因为我以前从来没有想过，花时间在空中对你们人类来说是一件如此奇怪的事情。而且它显然有时确实会在时差和福祉方面在精神和身体上影响我们。所以你以这种身份加入的事实真的太酷了。我还想更具体地谈谈你们最近进行的一个实验。所以你们推出了一项新活动和一个新系列，真正探讨了旅行与福祉之间的联系。但作为其中的一部分，你们做了一些
really cool research. And you guys know on this podcast, we love our science. We love our research. It's tasty. Can you dive into the premise of this for me? So Gemma, I'm a foodie like you. So things that taste good I'm really excited about. But I think, you know, we take a step back. Travel has made the world smaller, right? Particularly airline travel. It's opened up possibilities that many of us imagine were not possible. And now you get on a flight. for three, six, or ten hours, you can be in the other side of the world meeting people, places, experiences that you couldn't have imagined. And I think that's a remarkable, fantastic thing for all of us.
非常酷的研究。大家都知道在这个播客里，我们热爱科学。我们热爱研究。它很有趣。你能为我深入探讨一下这个前提吗，杰玛？我像你一样是个美食家。所以好吃的西我真的很兴奋。但我认为，（你知道的）我们退一步讲。旅行让世界变小了，对吧？特别是航空旅行。它开启了我们许多人想象中不可能实现的可能性。现在你登上了一架飞机，
And, you know, I think most of us probably couldn't live without it in terms of the possibilities that opens up. But specific to your question, yeah, we conducted an experiment with some Gen Z creators about the impact of travel, and the experiment was called Fly and Live Better. One, Delta wants to create a seamless premium experience for all of our customers in flight, but we feel like the flight experience can also help you live better.
飞行三小时、六小时或十小时，你就可以身处世界另一端，去遇见你无法想象的人、地点和经历。我认为这对我们所有人来说都是一件了不起的、美妙的事情。而且，（你知道的）我认为我们大多数人可能在它所开启的可能性方面都离不开它。但具体到你的问题，是的，我们与一些Z世代创作者就旅行的影响进行了一项实验，该实验名为“飞向并过得更好”（Fly and Live Better）。第一，达美航空希望为我们所有的飞行客户打造无缝的高端体验，但我们觉得飞行体验也可以帮助你过得更好。
And when you talk about the flight experience, it starts with your idea that you want to go somewhere and that you plan the trip and that you get to the airport and you check in, and the inflate experience and arriving at your destination refreshed and ready to enjoy whatever it is that's on your mind, whether that's business or pleasure. And so you kind of wanted to see how we could do this better, right? And how we could kind of elevate the experience.
而当你谈论飞行体验时，它始于你想去某个地方的想法，你计划了旅行，你到达机场并办理登机手续，以及机上体验，最后神清气爽地到达目的地，随时准备享受你心中的任何事情，无论是商务还是休闲。所以你有点想看看我们如何能做得更好，对吧？以及我们如何能够提升这种体验。
Talk me through what happened in this kind of research. I know you guys set some people on some flights. You gathered some data. Yeah. Tell me about how that went. Go as in-depth on the procedure as you want because I feel like we love to know, yeah, exactly what the data was and all of the changes. And you had four people, right? Can you talk a bit more about their experiences? Yeah. So we had four content creators, social media influencers. Their names were Gabe and Luan, as well as Sophie and Simi. There were two pairs. And we wanted to see a effects of travel on their health and well-being. And all of them were given aura ring to measure their physiologic parameters, so including their ready-to-scope score, their activity score during travel and at the destination, as well as they were given a survey to assess their emotional and social well-being during the trip and when they returned. And part of the research was to
跟我说说这种研究中发生了什么。我知道你们安排了一些人坐飞机。你们收集了一些数据。是的。告诉我进展如何。你可以尽可能深入地介绍这个过程，因为我觉得我们很想知道，是的，确切的数据是什么以及所有的变化。你们有四个人，对吧？能多谈谈他们的经历吗？好的。所以我们有四位内容创作者，也就是社交媒体网红。他们的名字叫盖布（Gabe）和卢安（Luan），还有苏菲（Sophie）和西米（Simi）。有两对。我们想看看旅行对他们的健康和福祉的影响。他们所有人都被发给了一个Oura戒指来测量他们的生理参数，包括他们的就绪分数，他们在旅行期间和目的地的活动分数，以及他们还接受了一项调查，以评估他们在旅行期间以及返回时的情绪和社会福祉。部分研究是将
send these two pairs of people to different destinations. One was a premium bucket list location in Copenhagen where they essentially flew Delta 1, stayed at a five-star hotel, and had premium experiences in Copenhagen. And the second was a more local closer trip, which we felt was also very much more accessible and fun, but didn't require the long flight or the change in time zones. And that was the Seattle, Washington. And they flew Delta Comfort. They had access to our sky clubs. And they also had curated Delta experiences in Seattle. And during the trip, we had the oral ring on them. So we were able to get metrics of their readiness score, their sleep score, their activity score, as well as
这两对人送到不同的目的地。一个是哥本哈根的高端心愿清单地点，他们基本上乘坐达美一等舱（Delta 1）飞行，住在五星级酒店，并在哥本哈根获得高端体验。第二个是更本土、更近的旅行，我们觉得这也更加平易近人且有趣，但不需要长途飞行或改变时差。那就是华盛顿州西雅图。他们乘坐达美舒适舱（Delta Comfort）。他们可以使用我们的飞凡贵宾室（Sky Clubs）。他们在西雅图也有策划好的达美体验。在旅行期间，我们在他们身上戴了Oura戒指。所以我们能够获得他们的就绪分数、睡眠分数、活动分数的指标，以及
surveys of their emotional social well-being on the trip. And I have to ask, was it different between the long-haul flight and the short domestic flight? Because as someone who, like, I feel like I fly overseas not all the time, but quite a bit. And when I fly overseas, it kind of takes it out of me. Did you see a difference between those two groups? Oh, yeah, very much so. I think what was good about both is their emotional or mental well-being and social well-being. went through the roof on both trips.
关于他们在旅行中的情绪社交福祉的调查。我不得不问，长途飞行和短途国内飞行之间有什么区别吗？因为作为一个（就像）我觉得我不是一直在海外飞行，但也飞得不少的人。当我飞往海外时，它有点让我筋疲力尽。你在那两组之间看到区别了吗？哦，是的，非常明显。我认为两者的优点在于他们的情绪或心理福祉以及社会福祉
Both trips were eye-opening, including the trip to Seattle, which was more local and accessible, as well as the bucket list trip to Copenhagen. On both trips, their emotional well-being and social well-being escalated and really because of, I think, the people and the experiences and different cultures they were able to see. The differences we saw were more on physical well-being, activity, and sleep. Obviously, you know, when you have,
在两次旅行中都直线上升。这两次旅行都大开眼界，包括去西雅图的旅行，那里更本土、更方便，还有去哥本哈根心愿清单的旅行。在两次旅行中，他们的情绪福祉和社会福祉都升级了，我认为这主要是因为人、经历以及他们能够看到的不同的文化。我们看到的差异更多是在身体福祉、活动和睡眠方面。显然，（你知道的）当你拥有
this longer flight to Copenhagen in Europe and it's a six to eight hour flight, it does take a lot out of you, whereas a shorter three-hour flight to Seattle, it was much easier for them to acclimate adjust to. But you know what I love about what you're saying is that the long haul flight, the short domestic travel, the dream trip to Copenhagen versus, you know, the around the corner trip for these participants to Seattle, both had very similar mental and social. perks and benefits. And you know why I think that that is such a cool finding from this is because obviously, like we talk about people in their 20s, right? And there's this huge emphasis on doing
去欧洲哥本哈根的这趟更长的飞行是一次六到八小时的飞行，它确实会让你消耗很多精力，而一趟较短的三小时飞往西雅图的飞行，对他们来说要容易得多去适应和调整。但你知道我最喜欢你说的是什么吗？那就是长途飞行、短途国内旅行、去哥本哈根的梦想之旅，与这些参与者去西雅图的转角之旅相比，两者都有非常相似的精神和社交津贴和好处。你知道为什么我认为这是这项研究中一个如此酷的发现吗？因为显然，就像我们谈论二十多岁的人一样，对吧？这里有一个巨大的强调，即做
your Euro gap year or traveling to as many countries as possible or, you know, bucket list travel items and definitely online we see people doing these amazing trips. And I love that what you're saying is just traveling in general, even if it's like to the town next door or to the city. over the way is still going to give you that kind of social and cultural and psychological and emotional expansion, which I think actually we need to talk about a little bit more because, again, it's not just these overseas amazing trips that are going to give that to you. It's these like small moments of intention, right? Absolutely. I think after they came back, we did a couple of interviews with them and it was
你的欧洲间隔年，或者尽可能多地去国家旅行，或者（你知道的）心愿清单旅行项目，绝对在线上我们看到人们做这些惊人的旅行。我喜欢你所说的是，总的来说，去旅行，哪怕只是去隔壁的小镇或旁边的城市，仍然会给你那种社会、文化、心理和情感上的扩展，我认为实际上我们需要多谈谈这一点，因为，再次强调，不仅仅是这些海外惊人的旅行才会给你带来这些。而是这些小的刻意时刻，对吧？绝对的。我认为他们回来后，我们对他们进行了一些采访，这很
interesting. When I asked them, did you get more from a shorter trip that was closer, or did you get more from a longer trip that was further away? And it wasn't a simple answer. The answers were different. And I think as a whole, the fact of traveling and seeing different places in of itself was rewarding. And, you know, at Delta, I know we like to say no one better connects the world. And for us that's connecting not just people to places and destinations, is connecting people to other people, other cultures, and ultimately experiences that can't really be replicated by, you know, Oculus or a pair of goggles in virtual reality. You know, being able to smell the flowers or go on the bike ride and feel the wind, blow in your hair, those are things that you can only experience
有趣。当我问他们时，你从更近的较短旅行中获得的更多，还是从更远的较长旅行中获得的更多？这不是一个简单的答案。答案是不同的。我认为作为一个整体，旅行和看到不同的地方本身就是有回报的。而且，（你知道的）在达美航空，我知道我们喜欢说“没有人能更好地连接世界”。对我们来说，这不仅是将人与地点和目的地连接起来，更是将人与其他人、其他文化连接起来，并最终将体验连接起来，这些体验是无法通过（你知道的）Oculus或虚拟现实中的一副眼镜来复制的。你知道，能够闻到花香或去骑自行车，感受风吹过你的头发，这些是你只能体验到的事情
in person. And it was pretty fun to hear from these content creators that, some of these views, be in Seattle and Copenhagen or dinners or experiences were so fantastic, they had to quickly create their content and then put that aside so they can actually enjoy the experience. Okay, this is also a cool finding that you're telling me is that when we are like in these spaces, travel actually allows us to disconnect further from, you know, social media. And yeah, for them, their work, which is something that I also find when I'm traveling. I'm like, it just like unlocks a whole new side of creativity for me as well because you get out of the space that is known and you get out of, you know, your responsibilities and you're able to just be present as kind of as humans were intended to be. Like they were intended to be curious and they were, we are intended to be to explore and to witness nature and witness beauty.
亲自。听到这些内容创作者说，其中一些观点，在西雅图和哥本哈根的晚餐或经历是如此美妙，以至于他们不得不迅速创作他们的内容，然后将其放在一边，以便他们能够真正享受这种体验，这真是太有趣了。好吧，这也是你告诉我的一个很酷的发现，那就是当我们身处这些空间时，旅行实际上使我们能够进一步从（你知道的）社交媒体中脱离出来。是的，对他们来说，他们的工作，这也是我在旅行时发现的。我只想说：它也为我解锁了一个全新的创造力侧面，因为你走出了熟悉的空间，你走出了（你知道的）你的责任，你能够只是存在，正如人类原本应该的那样。就像他们原本注定要好奇一样，并且他们是，我们注定要探索和见证自然，见证美。
Yeah, it's actually quite poetic. But I want to talk about something less poetic. but just as important to our humanness, which is the physical impacts of flying and also how we can better fly for our health. I feel like this generation is so health conscious and I know I am as well. And so any way that I can like elevate an experience so that my body endures less or so that I feel better is so important to me. What did you find with that? What does, flying kind of due from a physical perspective and how can we manage those things? Yeah, let's start with some of the findings we had.
是的，这其实相当诗意。但我想谈点不那么诗意，但对我们的人性同样重要的事情，那就是飞行的身体影响，以及我们如何能为了健康更好地飞行。我觉得这一代人非常有健康意识，我知道我也是。所以任何能让我提升体验的方式，以便我的身体承受更少或让我感觉更好的方式，对我来说都非常重要。你对此有什么发现吗？飞行从身体角度来看会造成什么影响，我们如何管理这些事情？好的，让我们从我们的一些发现开始。
You know, for the shorter trip, the four to five hour flight to Seattle, you know, our people arrived ready. Their readiness score was high and remained high. Their sleep score actually improved. So even though they were in a time zone three hours apart, their sleep score on average and improved eight points. and their activity score was much higher because they got out and about and they walked and they biked and they were physically active. And that's what we saw in Seattle, that there wasn't much
你知道，对于较短的旅行，四到五小时飞往西雅图的航班，（你知道的）我们的人到达时做好了准备。他们的就绪分数很高并且保持很高。他们的睡眠分数实际上有所改善。因此，即使他们在相差三个时区的地方，他们的睡眠分数平均也提高了八分。而且他们的活动分数要高得多，因为他们走出去，走路，骑自行车，而且他们身体很活跃。这就是我们在西雅图看到的，旅行或睡眠视角并没有带来太多的身体负担。他们到达时准备就绪，精神焕发，能够享受这个地点。现在，去哥本哈根的心愿清单或梦想之旅，显然是一次更长的旅行，有六个小时的时差。
of a physical toll from the travel or sleep perspective. They arrived ready, refreshed, and able to enjoy the location. Now, the bucket list or dream trip to Copenhagen, obviously a longer trip, six-hour time zone difference. You know, they flew Delta 1 first class and they were in the Delta One club, you know, before flight, and they loved the flight, including the beverages and the food and the premium service. But when you look at when they arrived, their readiness score was lower. Their sleep score dropped by nearly 20 points on their aura ring. I'd like to say, my top sleep score ever in my aura ring was a 94. So dropping to 74 would be pretty dramatic for me. And their activity score was high.
（你知道的）他们乘坐达美一等舱头等舱飞行，他们在飞行前在达美一等舱俱乐部，（你知道的）他们喜欢这次飞行，包括饮料、食物和高端服务。但当你看看他们到达时，他们的就绪分数较低。他们的睡眠分数在Oura戒指上下降了近20分。我想说，我Oura戒指上有史以来的最高睡眠分数是94。所以下降到74对戏剧性我来说将是相当巨大的。而且他们的活动分数很高。
So even though they were sleep deprived, tired, they still got out and did a lot of physical activities that was on average as high or not higher than what they were doing at their home. And here's the thing. I feel like when you're in your 20s and 30s and when you're younger, it's like I want to get every single little thing out of this experience. Like if I've flown first class, which that's like a bucket list item, if I've flown first class and I'm in this beautiful. city. Who cares if I'm jet lag. Like, I'm going to go and have pastries and I'm going to go shopping and I'm going to go see the museums. Like, you bet. And then it's like day two. Yeah. And you're like, I need to sleep for the next 24 hours or I'm, or I'm not going to, you're a zombie. And you were talking to me earlier. Like we, we were talking the other day about
所以即使他们睡眠不足、疲倦，他们仍然走出去做了很多体力活动，平均起来和他们在家里做的一样高，甚至更高。这就是问题所在。我觉得当你二十多岁、三十多岁，当你年轻的时候，就像我想从这种经历中榨取每一个小细节。就像如果我坐过头等舱，这是一个心愿清单项目，如果我坐了头等舱，在这个美丽的城市里。谁在乎我是不是有时差。就像，我要去吃糕点，我要去购物，我要去参观博物馆。就像，你敢打赌。然后就是第二天。是的。你会觉得自己需要在接下来的24小时里睡觉，否则你就是个僵尸。你刚才在跟我谈。就像我们，我们前几天在谈论
how you can kind of have the best of both worlds. Yeah. Some of the strategies that we can kind of adopt to land to have our readiness score higher. Maybe our sleep score a little bit lower, but not as low as it has to be. Particularly, I remember you talking about the importance of understanding your circadian rhythm. Can you expand on that a little bit? Yeah, I mean, the circadian rhythm is your own biological clock for a 24-hour day-night cycle. And if you think back in time before we had electricity and lights, that circadian rhythm was
你如何能鱼与熊掌兼得。是的。我们可以采用的一些策略，以便落地时让我们的就绪分数更高。也许我们的睡眠分数低一点，但不必那么低。特别是，我记得你谈到理解昼夜节律的重要性。你能对此多说一点吗？是的，我的意思是，昼夜节律是你自己的24小时昼夜周期的生物钟。如果你回想过去在有电和灯光之前，这种昼夜节律是
driven by daylight or sunlight. And everybody was on the same circadian rhythm. No one flew anywhere, but everybody was on the same day night cycle or circadian rhythm. But as you think about the advances in our society and community, you know, we invented electricity. We invented lights. We invented computers. We invented windows or rooms without windows. That completely disrupted our circadian rhythms. And if you think about what travel does, you and I, although you live in Australia and I live in Atlanta, we have our own circadian rhythms of day night when we're supposed to be awake, when we sleep, and get all the activities done. And when you travel to a different time zone that's six hours apart, you may be physically in Copenhagen,
由日光或阳光驱动的。每个人都处于相同的昼夜节律上。没有人坐飞机去任何地方，但每个人都处于相同的昼夜周期或昼夜节律上。但当你考虑我们社会和社区的进步时，（你知道的）我们发明了电。我们发明了灯。我们发明了电脑。我们发明了窗户或没有窗户的房间。这完全扰乱了我们的昼夜节律。如果你想想旅行的作用，你和我，虽然你住在澳大利亚，我住在亚特兰大，我们有我们自己的昼夜节律，什么时候我们应该醒着，什么时候我们睡觉，并完成所有的活动。当你旅行到一个相差六小时的不同时区时，你可能身体在哥本哈根，
but physiologically your body's function and your brain function is not at the same time that your body physically is there. So there's a separation between your physical person in Copenhagen and your physiologic person, everything that you know and you do and how you think and how much energy you have and how much focus you have is still in Atlanta. But there are things you can do to accelerate that conversion
但在生理上，你的身体功能和大脑功能并不在你的身体实际所在的时间。因此，你在哥本哈根的身体人与你的生理人之间存在着分离，你所知道的一切、你所做的一切、你如何思考、你拥有多少能量以及你拥有多少注意力都还在亚特兰大。但你可以做一些事情来加速这种转换
to a time zone that six hours different. And the things that you can do that make it worse. And those are the things I think we can talk about that are science-based that would help a traveler arrive refreshed and convert to that time zone faster. Yeah, so this is what I need to know because I've got to say, you're going to be mad at me, Henry. But when I get on a plane, I'm having my melatonin gummies and I'm also having a glass of wine. That's probably not the right thing to do. Because I know like the biggest one is like avoid set of lives, avoid alcohol. Why is that so important to do?
到一个相差六小时的时区。有些事情你可以做，使情况变得更糟。这些就是我认为我们可以谈论的基于科学的事情，这将有助于旅行者精神焕发地到达并更快地转换到那个时区。是的，这就是我需要知道的，因为我必须说，你会生我的气，亨利。但当我上飞机时，我有我的褪黑素软糖，我还喝了一杯酒。这可能不是正确的事情。因为我知道最大的一点是避免……避免酒精。为什么这样做如此重要？
Because I feel like a lot of us are like, well, I want to adjust so I'm going to, you know, try and push myself to sleep faster on the plane or delay sleep when I get there. What's wrong with the set of lives and the alcohol in this situation? Yeah. Well, you said it, right? The sedatives, the gummies, the alcohol, they may actually make you take. tired and have you fall asleep, but it's not restorative, restful sleep. We know that the restorative restful sleep is your REM sleep, rapid eye movement sleep, as well as your deep sleep. And believe or not, sedatives and hypnotics, like melatonin, ambient, Valium, or the gummies, they actually cause sleep, but not the right sleep. They don't induce the deep sleep and the REM sleep. So even
因为我觉得我们很多人都会觉得，好吧，我想要适应，所以你知道的，我会尝试在飞机上强迫自己更快入睡，或者到达目的地时晚点睡觉。这种生活方式和酒精在这个情况下有什么问题吗？是的。嗯，你刚才也说到了，对吧？镇静剂、软糖、酒精，它们可能确实会让你感到疲倦，并让你睡着，但这并不是那种能恢复精力的、安稳的睡眠。我们知道，能恢复体力的安稳睡眠是你的REM睡眠（快速眼球运动睡眠）以及你的深睡眠。不管你信不信，镇静剂和安眠药，比如褪黑素、安必恩、安定，或者那些软糖，它们确实能诱导睡眠，但却不是正确的睡眠。它们无法诱导深度睡眠和REM睡眠。所以即使
though you've been to sleep for it, five hours, eight hours, you're not rested because your body gets restorative, restful sleep with the deep sleep and REM sleep. And that's why the ambient, the volume, the alcohol, those are actually bad for you. You know, and some people, I'll take it to the next level. Some people arrive on scene and get their IV fluid infusions, and the fluids could be yellow, blue, and green. That might rehydrate you and make you feel temporarily better. One, I worry about why the fluid is green, blue, and yellow, and what additives are in there. But two, it doesn't really restore the body. It makes you feel temporarily better so you can do that activity, but it doesn't really restore your body physically just to get a liter of IV fluid.
你已经睡了五个小时、八小时，你也没有得到真正的休息，因为只有通过深度睡眠和REM睡眠，身体才能获得恢复性的、安稳的睡眠。这就是为什么安眠药、安定、酒精对你其实是有害的。你知道的，有些人还会把这推向极致。有些人一到达目的地就去进行静脉输液，那些液体可能是黄色、蓝色和绿色的。那可能会为你重新补水，让你暂时感觉好一些。首先，我担心为什么液体会是绿色、蓝色和黄色的，里面究竟添加了什么成分。但第二点是，它并没有真正恢复身体。它只是让你暂时感觉好一些，好让你去做那项活动，但仅仅输入一升静脉液体，并不能真正从身体上恢复你的状态。
So what you're saying is that we're doing all these things thinking they're helping, but what we should really be doing is what what should we be doing in terms of re-syncing our circadian rhythm? Yeah, yeah. So those give you a short-term benefit, but there's probably a long-term cost your pain, right? Because you'll probably arrive home needing a vacation from your vacation and to get more rest before you can, you know, re-enter your work life. So let's get back to the circadian rhythm. Light is important. We know that blue wavelength light is what stimulates your brain and the receptors in your retina to be alert and active for your daytime activities. We know that it's not just any blue-cutter light. There's a specific wavelength of blue light
所以你的意思是，我们做了所有这些以为有帮助的事情，但我们真正应该做的是——就重新同步我们的昼夜节律而言，我们到底应该做什么？对，对。所以那些方法能带给你短期的好处，但长远来看可能会付出代价，对吧？因为你回到家时，可能需要为你的假期再放个假，需要更多的休息，然后才能重新投入工作生活。所以我们回到昼夜节律上来。光线很重要。我们知道，蓝色波长的光能够刺激你的大脑和视网膜中的受体，让你在白天的活动中保持警觉和活跃。我们知道，这不仅仅是任何带有蓝色调的光。存在一种特定波长的蓝光，
that particularly informs your brain that says, hey, it's daytime, it's time to be awake and it stimulates you to be alert and active and have energy. And there's an opposite spectrum light that's in the red-orange wavelength that starts telling your brain and the receptors your retina to relax, to decrease your energy level, and your alertness, and to prepare for sleep. And that's what you get if all you were exposed to was sunlight without computers, iPads, iPhones, and light bulbs. And how do we then convert that time using light as a key component. So one technology or product I like to talk about that we've used is something called Sky View Lighting. This is not just colored lighting. Sky View lighting actually is a specific
它会明确地向你的大脑发送信号，说：“嘿，现在是白天，是该醒来的时候了”，并刺激你保持警觉、活跃和充满活力。而与之相反的光谱是红橙色波长的光，它开始告诉你的大脑和视网膜受体去放松，降低你的能量水平和警觉性，并为睡眠做准备。如果你接触的仅仅是没有电脑、iPad、iPhone和电灯泡照射的自然阳光，你就会得到这种光。那么，我们如何利用光作为关键组成部分来转换时间呢？所以，我喜欢谈论并使用过的一种技术或产品叫做“天景照明”（Sky View Lighting）。这不仅仅是彩色照明。天景照明实际上是一种特殊的光，
light that transmits a color that's blue wavelength, specifically for alertness during the day, and you can actually program it on your app to time it for the day in Copenhagen, Seattle, or Atlanta or Australia, but then it automatically realizes the 24-hour cycle and changes the color to red and orange to prepare you for sleep. So that is something you can do to almost tell your brain when it's daylight and when it's nighttime and do it with light as opposed to sunlight. Now, the science behind this is quite fascinating. I'm sure you'd be interested in it. This company was started by scientists that used to work at NASA, physicists. And they realized that in the International Space Station, which orbits the Earth,
它能发射出蓝色波长的光，专门用于白天的警觉性，你实际上可以在应用程序上对其进行编程，将其设置为哥本哈根、西雅图、亚特兰大或澳大利亚当地的时间，然后它会自动识别24小时的周期，并将颜色变为红色和橙色，为你的睡眠做准备。所以，你可以通过这种方式来告诉你的大脑什么时候是白天，什么时候是夜晚，并且是用光线来做到这一点，而不是靠自然阳光。现在，这背后的科学原理相当迷人。我确信你会对此感兴趣。这家公司是由以前在NASA工作的科学家、物理学家创立的。他们意识到，在绕地球运行的国际空间站上，
the day, night cycle of sunrise and sunset is 90 minutes. And there are windows on the space station, which can't be closed. So you're experiencing day and night every 90 minutes, and there's a crew of 10 astronauts who are expected to work in harmony and synchrony to maintain the space station and do the research they're doing. And they have to be on the same circadian rhythm. One person can't be asleep while the other person is ready to do the experiments or the research. What they found is without any intervention, the astronauts were becoming one to two hours per day,
日出和日落的昼夜循环是90分钟。空间站上有无法关闭的窗户。所以你每90分钟就要经历一次白天和黑夜，而且空间站里有10名宇航员，他们需要齐心协力、保持同步，以维护空间站并开展他们正在进行的研究。他们必须保持在相同的昼夜节律上。一个人不能在另一个人准备做实验或研究的时候睡觉。他们发现，如果没有进行任何干预，宇航员们的昼夜节律每天都在发生一到两个小时的偏移，
separated in their circadian rhythm as every day went by. And what they also found was 70, 80 percent of the astronauts were taking medications for sleep because they were trying to get sleep at the same time. But what they did was they put the sky view light in the space station and with 30 minutes of exposure to that light every single day, they can keep the 10 astronauts on the same circadian rhythm day and night so they can be functional, alert, and active, working as a team, if you will,
随着时间的推移，彼此越来越不同步。他们还发现，百分之七十到八十的宇航员都在服用安眠药，因为他们都在努力在同一时间入睡。但他们所做的是，他们在空间站里安装了天景照明灯，每天只需暴露在该光线下30分钟，他们就能让这10名宇航员保持在相同的昼夜节律下，无论白天黑夜，这样他们就能正常工作、保持警觉和活跃，像一个团队一样工作，如果你愿意这么形容的话，
working as a fully functional team. This kind of lighting has also been useful for submarines in the military, Right? Because if you're in a submarine and you're actually deployed underneath the water for two months with no daylight or sunlight, this at least tells your brain, this is daytime, and now this is nighttime, and keeps the entire crew of 300 submariners to be working as a team, as a functional single team. And the last group where this has been shown to be particularly effective is in places like Alaska, where in the winter you have 23 hours of night. And we know that, you know, prolonged nighttime or prolonged darkness can lead to seasonal effective disorders, that people can get mental health issues. So having this light be exposed to it and have the exposure to an artificial sunlight was very, very useful.
作为一个功能完全正常的团队在工作。这种照明方式也被证明对军队中的潜艇非常有用，对吧？因为如果你身处潜艇中，在水下部署长达两个月而见不到任何日光或阳光，这种照明至少能告诉你的大脑：现在是白天，现在是夜晚，从而让整整300名潜艇官兵能够像一个团队、一个功能齐全的单一团队一样协同工作。最后被证明这种照明特别有效的一个群体是在阿拉斯加这样的地方，那里的冬天有长达23小时的黑夜。我们知道，你知道的，长时间的黑夜或长时间的黑暗会导致季节性情绪失调，人们可能会出现心理健康问题。因此，接触这种光线并暴露在人造阳光下是非常非常有用的。
I can tell you that those are the scientific basis of how this skyview light has been used. Today, we've got sports teams like the New York Mets having this in their locker room. so that all their players can be fresh and alerted ready when the game starts. Yeah. So what you're saying to me is, like, if you want to fly better, you need to start really understanding the power of light, right? Yeah. So, you know, we are working with Skyview right now,
我可以告诉你，这就是天景照明被使用的科学基础。如今，纽约大都会队等运动队也在他们的更衣室里安装了这种灯，这样他们所有的队员在比赛开始时都能保持精力充沛、头脑清醒、随时准备应战。对。所以你对我说的是，如果你想获得更好的飞行体验，你需要真正开始了解光的力量，对吧？是的，所以，你知道，我们现在正在与Skyview合作，
Delta's partner with Skyview, to try to get a miniatized version of this light because the current lights are large. They're overhead lights, they're large desk lamps. But we're working on a miniatized version that's no bigger than a small iPad that you can take with you as carry on, and you can put into your hotel room
达美航空与Skyview合作，试图推出这种灯的缩小版，因为目前的灯具尺寸很大。它们是顶灯，或是大型台灯。但我们正在开发一种不比小型iPad大的缩小版，你可以把它作为随身行李带走，然后放进你的酒店房间里，
or put into wherever you are, so you have exposure to blue light and red-orange light, depending on circadian rhythm. We're literally excited about it because this can help you convert your time and the different time zones faster. So that hopefully will be ready for testing,
或者放在你所在的任何地方，这样你就可以根据你的昼夜节律接触到蓝光和红橙光。我们对此感到无比兴奋，因为这可以帮助你更快地转换时间和不同的时区。希望它能准备好进行测试，
and we're going to test it with our crew in the next couple of months to see if that works. I would like to pivot actually to another company we've worked with, which is all called Fount and Fly Kit. I haven't you have one over here. And this is the product they sell. It's Fountain Flight Kit. Again, this is interventions you can do to try to convert your circadian rhythm faster, right?
我们将在接下来的几个月里与我们的机组人员一起测试它，看看效果如何。其实我想把话题转向我们合作过的另一家公司，叫做Fount和他们的“飞行装备”（Fly Kit）。我没记错的话你这里就有一个。这就是他们销售的产品，叫“飞行装备”（Fount Flight Kit）。同样，这也是你可以采取的一些干预措施，以试图更快地重置你的昼夜节律，对吧？
So if we do nothing, we'll probably convert to that six to eight hour time zone difference over a matter of two to four days, depending on how quickly you acclimate and adjust. If you do the volume, melatonin, ambient, and gummies actually may delay it and take longer. This, again, like Skyview, is meant to try to decrease that conversion to a matter of one or two days. So this company was founded by some Navy SEALs. You know, as you think about the Navy SEALs and our military, they may need to deploy. and they need that crew ready to carry out their mission.
所以如果我们什么都不做，我们可能需要两到四天的时间才能适应那六到八小时的时区差异，这取决于你适应和调整的速度。如果你使用安定、褪黑素、安眠药和软糖，实际上可能会拖慢进度，花费更长的时间。这个产品和Skyview一样，旨在将这种适应时间缩短到一两天内。所以这家公司是由几位海豹突击队员创立的。你知道，当你想到海豹突击队员和我们的军队时，他们可能需要随时出征，
And using supplements, they actually look at your time zone. They have an app, depending on where you're flying, your specific flight, what time you're flying, the time zone difference when you arrive. Their app tells you when you take these supplements, which includes a mixture of magnesium, vitamin C, vitamin B6, vitamin B12, as well as omega-3 fatty X. acids, really to help your body adjust to that local time zone faster. And it can actually show you how much you shift it. Within the app, it also recommends when you should eat, what you should eat, how much you
并且需要队员随时准备好执行任务。他们会使用补充剂，并实际查看你的时区。他们有一个应用程序，根据你飞行的目的地、你的具体航班、飞行时间以及抵达时的时区差异，他们的应用程序会告诉你何时服用这些补充剂，其中包括镁、维生素C、维生素B6、维生素B12以及欧米伽-3脂肪酸的混合物，真正帮助你的身体更快地适应当地的时区。它甚至可以向你展示你调整了多少。在该应用程序中，它还建议你何时吃东西、吃什么、吃多少，
should eat, and when you should go to bed. Again, trying to help your body make that time zone conversion faster so you arrive ready, refresh to enjoy your trip. And lastly, what they provide in the kit is my favorite, which are these blue blocker glasses. These blue blocker glasses essentially will block out 99% of that blue light we talked about. So you put these on, everything looks like a shade of orange. You've seen these being sold by other makers.
以及你应该在什么时候上床睡觉。同样，这是为了帮助你的身体更快地完成时区转换，让你到达时精神饱满、神清气爽地去享受你的旅程。最后，他们在装备中提供的是我最喜欢的东西，也就是这些防蓝光眼镜。这些防蓝光眼镜基本上可以阻挡我们之前谈到的99%的蓝光。所以你戴上它，一切看起来都呈橙色调。你可能见过其他制造商销售这种产品。
But these are well made. They block out 99% of that blue wavelength light so that when it's nighttime and you're still on your iPad, your iPhone, or on your computer like you're now, you can. put this on and you can do your activity, but you're not getting the blue wavelength light that's keeping you awake alert as of its daytime. So with that combination, you're able to convert your time so much faster. And the most exciting thing that I think Fly Kit are working on is trying to create what we call a digital twin. So creating a digital twin of Gemma so that we know that this, what is this digital twin's physiologic circadian rhythm in Copenhagen and how far is she
但这些做工很好。它们阻挡了99%的蓝光波长，这样当夜幕降临，你仍在使用iPad、iPhone或像现在这样用电脑时，你可以戴上它，然后你可以进行你的活动，但你不会接收到那些让你保持清醒、以为还是白天的高能量蓝光。通过这种组合，你能够以快得多的速度转换你的时间。我认为Fly Kit正在研究的最令人兴奋的事情是尝试创建我们所谓的“数字孪生”。也就是为杰玛（Gemma）创建一个数字孪生，这样我们就能知道，这个数字孪生在哥本哈根的生理昼夜节律是什么样的，它与哥本哈根的实际时间相比，
deviated from the actual time in Copenhagen versus the time in Australia. Depending on where you want to be, right? You can sit your time to, I'm going to Australia tomorrow. I want to be ready for Australia or I'm in Copenhagen for a week and I want to be in a time zone of Copenhagen. So that digital twin can tell you based on measurables, biometrics, as well as if you've taken the supplements, if you've done the exercises, if you've done the eating and sleeping, where are you in terms of your conversion?
和澳大利亚的时间偏离了多少。取决于你想去哪里，对吧？你可以将时间设置为：“我明天要去澳大利亚。我想要为澳大利亚做好准备”或者“我在哥本哈根呆了一周，我想处于哥本哈根的时区”。所以这个数字孪生可以根据可测量数据、生物特征，以及你是否服用了补充剂、是否进行了锻炼、是否按时饮食和睡觉，来告诉你目前的时区转换进展到了什么阶段。
That is honestly amazing. And the fact that people haven't done this sooner is shocking to me because I'm signing up for all of these things. I like the light idea. Like if I could pack that in my carry on and that's going to save me like a day of explore time. Like I'm doing that in a heartbeat. And also the fact that you're saying to me like what we eat.
这老实说太惊人了。人们没有早点这么做，这让我感到震惊，因为我已经报名参与所有这些项目了。我喜欢灯光的这个创意。如果我可以把它打包进随身行李里，并且这能帮我省下一整天的探索时间，我一定会毫不犹豫地这么做。还有你对我说的话，关于我们吃什么、
And when we choose to sleep, even if it's like 15 minutes earlier. can make such profound shifts, I feel like it's going to prevent us from going into travel and being like, okay, cool. So I've just lost two days when it's probably been really expensive for me to get here. And this is like a once in a lifetime trip. Like you want all of that time maximized. And I think it, sorry, to make one final point, because I'm kind of just blown away by this. I think it also emphasizes that we think of travel as like purely, I don't really know how we of it. We just think of it as like a form of transport, but it is so mental and it is so emotional and emotional and physical and there is like a deeper meaning to it. So talk about how Delta specifically
以及我们选择什么时候睡觉，哪怕只是提前15分钟，都能带来如此巨大的转变，我觉得这将阻止我们在旅行时陷入这种状况：“好吧，酷。我刚刚损失了两天时间，而我到这里可能花了很多钱，这还是一生难忘的旅行。”你希望所有这些时间都被最大化利用。而且我认为它——抱歉，最后补充一点，因为我真的被这个深深震撼了。我认为它也强调了这一点：我们把旅行看作是纯粹的……我其实不知道我们是怎么看待它的。我们只是把它看作一种交通方式，但它是如此关乎心理，如此关乎情感，情感与身体，其中蕴含着更深层的意义。所以，谈谈达美航空具体如何能够
can personalize and is thinking about wellness more as part of someone's journey to their destination. Yeah. We know that travel can be heard, right? You know, there are delays, you know, there are times when it's very crowded in every seat. And a lot of people, like you said, think of air travel as how do I get from point A to point B with the least amount of burden or trauma to be. But at Delta, we're trying to reimagine that. We're thinking about your whole curb to claim experience as a holistic experience. And how can we make that travel experience as seamless and as delightful as possible. So it starts with our flight Delta app, right?
实现个性化，并且正在将健康视为旅客目的地之旅的一部分来进行思考。是的。我们知道旅行可能会很艰难，对吧？你知道的，会有延误，你知道的，有时每个座位都挤满了人。很多人，就像你说的，把航空旅行看作是如何从A点到B点，并尽量减少给自身带来的负担或创伤。但在达美航空，我们正试图重新构想这一点。我们将你从出发到取行李的全过程视为一种整体体验。我们如何能让那种旅行体验尽可能无缝且令人愉快。所以这始于我们的达美航空应用程序，对吧？
Because this is where you plan a trip and you book your flights. You check in for your boarding pass and you know when you're supposed to arrive and you board the plane. But I think every step along the way, we're trying to make that experience as personalized to you as possible, understanding you are a traveler with Delta, that you're not just traveling with us once. We know that if Gemma is one of our Sky Mouse members and has traveled with us multiple times,
因为这是你规划行程和预订航班的地方。你办理登机手续获取登机牌，你知道自己应该什么时候到达并登机。但我认为在整个过程的每一步，我们都在努力让这种体验对你来说尽可能个性化，理解你是一位乘坐达美航空的旅客，你不仅仅是和我们飞行一次。我们知道，如果杰玛是我们的尊爵会（Sky Miles）会员，并且多次与我们同行，
we know what she prefers, we know what she likes, we know what she's looking for. And using that information to cater or create your future travel experiences is what we're aiming for. Right. So to that end, for example,
我们就知道她的偏好，知道她喜欢什么，知道她在寻找什么。利用这些信息来迎合或创造你未来的旅行体验，正是我们的目标。好，为此，举个例子，
we now have a SkyMouse member's free Wi-Fi, high-speed Wi-Fi for every single person on board to the point where, If you're a Skymouse member, you're on any of our planes, whether it's within the United States or international, you can link up to our Wi-Fi and stream Netflix. You can look at YouTube TV, who's an exclusive partner of Delta with their content that's coming. We're also partnered with Uber so that if you arrive and we know that you want an Uber, you can book that in flight with the Wi-Fi and schedule it. Or you can book it as soon as you're ready to plane. those are personalized experiences and a seamless experience for our travelers. And I think that's one of the
我们现在为每一位登机的乘客提供尊爵会会员免费Wi-Fi、高速Wi-Fi，甚至在以下情况下：如果你是尊爵会会员，搭乘我们的任何航班，无论是美国国内还是国际航班，你都可以连接我们的Wi-Fi并观看Netflix流媒体。你可以观看YouTube TV的内容，他们是达美航空即将推出的独家内容合作伙伴。我们还与优步（Uber）合作，如果你抵达后我们知道你需要一架Uber，你可以通过Wi-Fi在航班上预订并安排它。或者你一准备好下飞机就可以预订。这些都是为我们的旅客提供的个性化体验和无缝体验。我认为这也是实际考虑不仅选择从亚特兰大到澳大利亚能买到的最低价航班的好处之一，
benefits of actually considering not choosing just the lowest cost flight you can get from Atlanta to Australia, that you consider becoming a loyalty member, like a Skyny's one member, with Delta or other airlines, where this opens up a world of experiences and curated experiences for you, including, I think One of the things I love the most is we recently added Shake Shickshack burgers on our flights, which can order in advance. Oh, I saw this. It's a great burger. I saw this on TikTok. Yeah, that's so cool.
你会考虑成为达美航空或其他航空公司的忠诚度计划会员，比如尊爵会会员，这会为你打开一个体验世界和精选体验的世界，其中包括，我认为我最喜欢的事情之一是我们最近在航班上增加了 Shake Shack 汉堡，可以提前预订。哦，我看过这个。这是一个很棒的汉堡。我在TikTok上看到了。是的，太酷了。
I just had it on my trip from Salt Lake City to New York, and I got to say, it was as good as a Shake Shack Burger at the restaurant. The burger was smashed, crispy on the outside. They separated the buns, so it didn't get soggy. The lettuce, tomatoes, and onions. were in a separate bowl, and they gave you their shake shack brownie and the potato chips. It was delicious. And to know that you can order that before the flight was fantastic and knowing that it was ready for you.
我刚在从盐湖城飞往纽约的航班上吃过，我得说，它和餐厅里的 Shake Shack 汉堡一样美味。汉堡肉饼是压扁煎制的，外皮酥脆。他们把汉堡胚分开放置，所以面包不会变湿。生菜、西红柿和洋葱
The other thing we've added a few years ago is, you know, if you're checking in a bag, we now tell you when it's been loaded. So you know that your bag has been loaded on the plane. And then when it's coming off the plane and when it's at the claim. So you never have to worry that my bag make it with me. Is it still left in Austria? and I'm flying to New York. So those are the things that are just so fantastic.
放在一个单独的碗里，他们还附赠了 Shake Shack 布朗尼蛋糕和薯片。太好吃了。而且知道你可以在航班起飞前预订这个，这太棒了，而且知道它已经为你准备好了。我们几年前增加的另一项功能是，你知道的，如果你托运了行李，我们现在会告诉你它什么时候被装载上机。所以你知道你的行李已经装上了飞机。然后当它从飞机上卸下以及在行李提取处时。所以你永远不必担心我的行李有没有跟我一起过来。它是不是还留在奥地利，
And hopefully we're hoping that, you know, given it's 2025 and everybody's digital and AI enhanced, that you can do all these things within the flight Delta app and that you never have to call someone or go in line. And even in the setting of an IRAP or irregular operations where weather or something else is interrupting the flight, that you can change a flight or rebook a night. or re-book another flight or have something done for you right within the app. The fact, I don't know who your product team is,
而我正飞往纽约。所以这些事情真的是太棒了。希望我们期望，鉴于现在是2025年，每个人都数字化且有AI赋能，你可以在达美航空的应用程序中完成所有这些事情，再也不需要打电话给任何人或排队了。甚至在发生IRAP（不规则运行）或由于天气或其他原因导致航班中断的情况下，你也可以直接在应用程序内更改航班、重新预订另一个晚上的航班，或者重新预订另一趟航班，或者为你安排好一切。事实上，我不知道你们的产品团队是谁，
but they are working over time because that is every single thing and every single frustration I have ever had with flying. Gone. Like, is my bag missing? Oh, how am I going to get to my hotel? The airport, do I have to pack my own snacks because the airplane food is like not very tasty?
但他们肯定在加班加点，因为这涵盖了我坐飞机时遇到的每一件事和每一个沮丧瞬间。全都消失了。比如：我的行李丢了吗？哦，我要怎么去酒店？机场里，我是不是得自己带零食，因为飞机餐不是很好吃？
Like, am I going to have, am I going to be able to like work on the flight? All done, all minimized. It's just like, I love when companies are just like, yeah, we recognize that's a problem. And we're not just going to be like, deal with it. We're going to actually do something about it. I'm a big fan. And also, I will say, advice to my 20-something listeners, which is probably all of you,
比如：我在航班上能工作吗？全都搞定，全都最小化了。我就是喜欢那些公司说：“是的，我们承认这是个问题，而且我们不只是叫你‘忍着点’，我们真的要采取行动来解决它。”我是个超级粉丝。而且我也要说，给二十多岁听众的建议——你们可能大多都是这个年龄段，
please sign up for Sky Miles or please sign up for a loyalty program with your airline. Obviously, we're hoping that it's Delta for Henry. But it's like this thing that I wish I'd started doing earlier. and I was actually at my run club the other day. And my friend was showing me all the air miles that she had accumulated over like years of travel. And we did the math. And this was just like incidental travel. Like she's going home for a funeral.
请注册加入 Sky Miles（尊爵会）或者请注册你乘坐航空公司的常客奖励计划。显然，我们希望那是达美航空。但这就好像是我希望自己能早点开始做的一件事。我前几天去跑步俱乐部时，我的朋友向我展示了她多年旅行积攒下来的所有航空里程。我们算了一笔账。这其实只是零星的旅行。比如她回家参加葬礼，
She had to fly for work. You know, she went to Europe last year. And we were looking at all the miles and it was like she could go to New York for free. It's like an investment. It's like investing. And you literally aren't doing anything other than just doing the normal travel that you would do. But I always think it's worth paying more to travel with the same airline because you get these perks and because you get this thing at the end of the day. Like it's worth the $50 more, the $75 more because you literally get free flights out of it.
她因公出差（她去年去了欧洲）。我们看着所有的里程，发现她可以免费去纽约。这就像是一笔投资。这就像是在投资。而且你实际上什么都没做，只是在进行你本来就要进行的正常旅行。但我一直觉得，多花点钱坐同一家航空公司的航班是值得的，因为你能得到这些福利，而且最后还能得到这个成果。多花50美元、75美元是值得的，因为你真的能从中获得免费机票。
So I'm glad you brought that up. I do have one final question for you because we've been chatting away for a while. maybe two final questions, but I'm going to start with this one, which is from your experience, from your experience when you were younger to where you are now, what is one thing you wish people in their 20s knew about travel or did differently about air travel? What's a piece of advice for us? One of the things I think, you know, what I've realized is very few people get on a plane to get miles, right?
所以我很高兴你提到这个。我确实有一个最后的问题要问你，因为我们已经聊了一会儿了。也许是两个最后的问题，但我先从这个问题开始：根据你的经验，从你年轻时的经历到现在的成就，你希望20多岁的人在旅行方面知道一件事，或者在航空旅行方面做出什么不同的改变？有什么建议可以给我们吗？其中一件事我想，你知道，我意识到的是，很少有人为了攒里程而去坐飞机，对吧？
When people get on a plane to travel to somewhere, no one's doing it just to get their sky miles or loyalty perks, people get on a plane for a reason. And that reason could be business, that reason could be for pleasure, that reason could be a funeral, right? Everybody's got a purpose when they get on the plane. And I think travel in 2025 has become so ubiquitous
当人们坐飞机去某个地方旅行时，没有人仅仅是为了获得他们的 Sky Miles 或忠诚度福利，人们坐飞机是有原因的。这个原因可能是商务，这个原因可能是休闲，这个原因可能是为了参加葬礼，对吧？每个人坐飞机都有一个目的。我认为2025年的旅行已经变得如此普遍，
and different now. the thing that's made the most difference for me is self-care. And whether you're flying premium in first class or you're in the back of the plane in the middle road, there are things you can do to make that experience better for yourself in terms of self-care. Right, Delta's going to do everything possible to personalize to enhance your experience.
而且现在不同了。对我而言改变最大的事情是自我关爱。无论你坐的是头等舱的尊贵舱位，还是机舱后排的中间座位，都有一些事情你可以做，从自我关爱的角度为自己提升那种体验。对吧，达美航空将尽一切可能实现个性化，以提升你的体验。
But things that I do now, that I don't travel without, are I love my eye mask that's memory foam and goes over my face. I love my sleep pillow that, you know, prevents me from having a crick on my neck if I fall asleep. And I remind myself to drink a lot of water and drink a lot of hydration. And that is, you know, sort of foundational change if we can all remember that. Also, to add to your list, noise cancelling headphones, guys.
但我现在会做、出门旅行必带的事情是：我喜欢我的记忆棉眼罩，它可以完美贴合我的脸。我喜欢我的睡眠枕，你知道的，如果我睡着了，它可以防止我的脖子酸痛。我时刻提醒自己要多喝水，保持身体水分充足。这可以说是，你知道的，如果我们都能记住的话，这是一个根本性的改变。另外，还要加到你的清单里的是，降噪耳机，伙计们。
Yeah, yeah. You've got to invest in a pair of alerts. Yeah. It's a new world, right? It's like, hey, it's quiet. I know. The first time I ever bought noise cancelling headphones was like when, because I actually don't, we haven't talked about this at all, but I used to have a really big fear of flying. And which is, I don't know how this hasn't come up, but the listeners know. Jim, I would tell you, and I want to reassure you, commercial airline flying is probably one of the safest activities you can do. It's safer than driving and it's safer than walking on the streets of New York in terms of accidents. We really don't see them.
是的，是的。你得投资一副降噪耳机。这是一个新世界，对吧？就像是：嘿，世界安静了。我知道。我第一次买降噪耳机的时候，是因为——其实我们根本没谈过这个，但我以前对坐飞机有很大的恐惧。而且，我不知道这怎么一直没提出来，但听众们都知道。杰玛，我要告诉你，我想让你放心，商业航空飞行绝对是你所能从事的最安全的活动之一。就事故率而言，它比开车安全，比走在纽约街头安全。我们真的很少看到这类事故。
Despite some of the things you see, it is still absolutely very safe. And I can tell you that the airlines across the world compete on everything except safety. You know, whether you're airfronts, KLM, Delta, we all share safety protocols and we strive to be the safest form of travel period full stop. And I think you're in good hands. I hope you feel safer and better about flying. I do. Look at that little industry secret, guys. That is actually, I did not know that. That makes me feel a lot better. Yeah. I think this is all we have time for. I want to thank you so much for joining me and with all your knowledge and all your insight and sharing like the latest and greatest developments. I think the real takeaway from this episode is just to be intentional about your trip and to be intentional about self-care on your trip. Would you agree? Absolutely.
尽管你可能看到过一些报道，但它绝对是非常安全的。我可以告诉你，世界各地的航空公司在除了安全之外的所有事情上都展开竞争。你知道，无论是法航、荷航还是达美航空，我们都共享安全协议，并致力于成为最安全的交通方式，句号，毫无疑问。我想你现在应该感到很安心。我希望你对飞行的感觉更安全、更好了。确实如此。看吧，行业小秘密，伙计们。这实际上——我以前真不知道。这让我感觉好多了。是的。我想这就是我们今天所有的全部时间了。非常感谢你加入我，分享你所有的知识、所有的见解，以及最新、最伟大的发展。我认为本期节目真正的核心收获就是：对你的旅行保持走心，并在旅行中注重自我关爱。你同意吗？绝对同意。
It's absolutely to be intentional. And, you know, from our creators on their trips, the last thing I would advise your listeners is find out what makes you feel better and brings you joy. And for Gabe, it was playing his guitar. For Luan, it was journaling. Simi also enjoyed journaling. For Sophie, it was getting a massage. But each of us has something that brings us joy and helps us restore ourselves and that self-care
绝对要做到走心。而且，你知道的，从我们的创作者的旅行来看，我要给听众的最后一个建议是：找出能让你感觉更好、给你带来快乐的事情。对加布（Gabe）来说，是弹吉他。对路安（Luan）来说，是写日记。西米（Simi）也很喜欢写日记。对苏菲（Sophie）来说，是做按摩。但我们每个人都有能给自己带来快乐、帮助我们恢复状态以及进行自我关爱的事物。
component. So thank you for this opportunity, Jen. I really appreciated talking with you. Yeah. Don't neglect it just because you're traveling, guys. You don't want to come back and need another vacation from your vacation. Thank you again to everyone who has listened and who has joined us for this episode. I want to invite you to watch the Fly and Live Better series on YouTube. It is very, very cool and I love when companies do their own research and bring like an experimental perspective to an everyday experience. I'm going to leave a link. in the description and also join Sky Miles for access to more experiences. That's my biggest tip for people in their 20s. Join a loyalty program. Join Sky Miles. Even if you literally
所以谢谢你给我这个机会，杰姆。我很感激能和你交谈。是的，伙计们，不要仅仅因为在旅行就忽略了这一点。你可不想回来之后，还需要为你的假期再放个假。再次感谢每一位收听并加入我们这一期节目的听众。我想邀请大家在YouTube上观看“Fly and Live Better”系列节目。它真的非常非常酷，我特别喜欢那些自己做研究并将实验视角带入日常体验的公司。我会在简介里留下链接。另外，加入 Sky Miles 以获得更多体验。这是我对20多岁年轻人的最大建议：加入忠诚度计划。加入 Sky Miles。即使你实际上
only travel once a year, you have no idea how much it adds up. But again, thank you to Henry. And as always, be safe, be kind. Be gentle to yourself. We will talk very, very soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
一年只旅行一次，你也不知道它积少成多能带来多少收获。再次感谢亨利。一如既往，注意安全，保持善良。对自己温柔一点。我们很快就会再聊。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，精神坚韧、体能训练以及构建心理韧性的科学。经历一些艰难险阻，你将破茧成蝶，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》（即 TWO percent）。这是一个IHeart播客。真人保证。谢谢。这集节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。